يعني ونحن في هذا المكان الان عوده طواقم
جهاز الدفاع المدني بعد خروجهم الى مهمه
استهداف في مخيم النصيرات وتلقي يعني
اشاره من قبل يعني ضابط العمليات بوجود
استهداف في المنطقه في منطقه النصيرات
خرجت هذه الطواقم بشكل سريع لانتشال
الاصابات ويعني الشهداء لربما يعني سنتعرف
عن ماهيه الاستهدافات والتعامل مع يعني
الاستهدافات مع ضباط الاسعاف هؤلاء
الطواقم يعني ينتظرون في اي لحظه
للخوض
بالميدان لانتشال الاصابات لانتشال
الشهداء لانقاذ من يتم انقاذه من
المواطنين احنا شاع بنخلص رغم كل اللي
بيصير فينا ورغم كل الشهداء ورغم كل كل
الاحداث اللي بتصير معنا بدنا نعيش بدنا
نعيش بدنا نعيش بسنا الشباب يعني بث جهدهم
ووجودهم في الميدان واستمرارهم في العمل
ان شاء الله احنا مستمرين يعني حتى
النهايه ورسالتنا طبعا للعالم كله لشعبنا
وابناء شعبنا بالخص انه احنا موجودين
طرفكم وين ما يكون حنكون بجانبكم رغم قله
الامكانيات وشحن الامكانيات الموجوده
حنعمل ليل نهار من اجل حمايه شعبنا قدر
المستطاع قدر على قدر الامكانيات الموجوده
رسالتنا للعالم انه العدوان هذا لازم يقف
عن الشعب الفلسطيني وقل شيء اللي هو
التوجه لجهاز الدفاع المدني كجهاز حمايه
مدنيه بتوفير اقل حاجه الامكانيات
الاساسيه من بواق من اللي هو معدات اطفاء
سيارات اطفاء انقاذ لانه السيارات
الموجوده طرفنا والمعدات موجوده طرفنا
[موسيقى]
متهالكه يعني جزء من طواقم الدفاع المدني
تصلي جزء اخر يعني هنا يعمل على يعني
نظافه المكان رغم انه مكان من التراب ولكن
يعملون على تنظيف الاواني نظافه هذه
المكان الذي يتواجد به هنا طواقم الدفاع
المدني ونستمع هنا في الخلفيه الى
الاستطلاع المكثف ل انهم لازالوا في
عملهم في هذا المكان طبعا احنا بنتوجع على
اماكن الاستهدافات بناء على الاصواط
الانفجارات بنتبع ه الاصواط او من
خلال ممكن في في النهار ممكن نشوف اماكن
خروج
الدخان طبعا العمل بم بصعوبه في ه في ظل ه
الظروف لانه احن بنتعرض لخطر بشكل متواصل
لانه احن ممكن نتعرض في اي لحظه للاستهداف
من خلال حركتنا و جولاتنا الميدانيه اللي
بنعملها عشان نقدر نحدد مكان
الاستهداء بالتاكيد يعني الان يتجهز هذا
الفريق للذهاب الى ماكن الاستهداف في مخيم
النصيرات استهداف جديد في النصيرات يتجهز
الطاقم الان للذهاب والانطلاق الى اماكن
الاستهدافات الجديده كما نتابع هنا فرق
الانقاظ هي جاهزه تماما الان للانطلاق
لمخيم النصرا لوجود استهداف في
تلك